(knocks on door)
-Wanted to see me sir?
-Sit down, Kurt.
Thank you, coach.
I prefer to stand.
Alright. Go ahead then.
Tell me.
Tell you what?
Why a team worth $800 million,
one of the most complex
offenses ever built,
should put you in
the driver's seat?
You're too old to be a rookie,
too green to be a pro.
So why in the world would
I give you this shot?
(inspirational music)
All my life, I defined
myself through sports.
I've always come up empty.
Coach, I can win for you.
You need to start thinking
about life after football, son.
We gave you the chance.
We're letting you go.
I was meant for
something. Something more.
You think
you can be that guy?
Yeah, I do
What are you doing here?
I wasn't ready for
it, but I am now.
You defied all odds.
I waited for it.
I bled for it.
I know who I am.
And I know why I'm here.
If you give me a chance,
[Commentator] Green went down
hard and is not getting up.
I will not let you down.
You were born for this.
Something special
about you, son.
Destiny
belongs to the underdogs.
You want to prove that?